in a new advertisement the National
Rifle Association warns left-wing
journalists that quote time is running
out for them here it is - every line
member of the media - every Hollywood
phony - the role model athletes who use
their free speech to alter and undermine
what our flag represents to the
politicians who would rather watch
America burn than lose one ounce of
their own personal power - the late
night hosts who think their opinions are
the only opinions that matter - the joy
an reads the morning Joe's the Mika's to
those who stayin honest reporting with
partisanship to those who bring bias and
propaganda to CNN The Washington Post
and The New York Times your time is
running out
that stain lash of course in the ad she
speaks for the NRA and she joins us
tonight dan thanks for coming up thanks
for having me Tucker so you are being
criticized for inciting violence some
say by that phrase time is up what did
what does that mean well times up of
course is a play on the times up
movement the Hollywood progressivism
that for so long tolerated and
celebrated people like Roman Polanski
and Woody Allen and Harvey Weinstein but
also at the very end of that video there
Tucker it was an announcement for a
program that I'm doing for NRA TV
because I think that a free people have
the right to hold accountable and to
Fisk and fact-check a free press and so
that's what it's all about now to be
clear I don't believe in universal
statements and that's why to those
people in the media and those people in
Hollywood who are pushing propaganda or
who are lying yes this is an indictment
of you and the program for NRA TV which
launches at the end of this month Tucker
is focusing on media malpractice and
holding accountable that media
malpractice which we have seen tons up
particularly in the past year what do
you think that comes from where do you
think the gut the gut level animus you
see in the media toward NRA toward gun
owners where does that come from I think
it's just honestly I think that there
are a lot of people who don't understand
middle America I think that they don't
understand individuals who are Second
Amendment practitioners I mean you've
talked about this on your show
before Tucker and I I mean I edited
under Andrew Breitbart big journalism
for this very reason I was entirely fed
up with mainstream media legacy media
and the malpractice thereof and we saw
how they disparaged and impune the
characters of those people the members
of the Tea Party we saw them ignore
maligned black conservatives they ignore
and maligned conservative women they
ignore maligned gay conservatives they
it's it and they they bash good people
in flyover nation who were good enough
to vote for the Clintons for how many
years but then when they turn around and
they vote for Donald Trump suddenly
Tucker those people become bigots and
racists and we've watched media malign
so many good Americans and seem to only
report one side of the story I mean for
instance just look at everything that's
happened with parkland where's the media
focusing on the Broward sheriff for
instance fighting fighting the Miami
Herald who has done epic work they've
done amazing work in this in the story
in there they filed a lawsuit against
the Broward Sheriff's Office trying to
get this video that the sheriff once
promised that he was going to release
where's the focus on that or the media
or the political class that has let the
mental crisis spiral out of control
instead honestly Tucker you know what
they're writing about they're writing
about my musical taste in in Newsweek
and and focusing on my appearance and
and me as a person and my husband and
law-abiding gun owners all across the
United States instead of doing their due
diligence and acting like the watchdog
of the people so who watches the
Watchers that's the question if you're
gonna try and take people's guns away
don't you think you have a moral
obligation and prevent them from
protecting themselves don't you think of
an obligation to protect them better
than our our elites are now doing yeah
that's what I don't understand here
we're looking at multiple systemic
failures coming from the government that
failed to protect us all the while we
have all of these individuals telling us
well you can trust the government to
protect you
we're really because they didn't with
Sutherland Springs and they didn't with
Garland Texas and they didn't with San
Bernardino and they didn't with the Navy
Yard and they didn't in parkland and
they didn't in Charleston I could go on
and on because there were balls dropped
every in every single one of those
instances Tucker and the political class
has been largely silent they have
invented they haven't been moved to make
sure that the background check system
works like Wayne LaPierre has called for
25 years to do
and so I I mean this is this is where
the focus that's where honestly that's
where the focus should be in all of this
but I you know to the point of people
trying to say that somehow fact-checking
media is violent the progressive left
has been violent for a very long time
and I can't take seriously the criticism
criticisms of people Tucker who ignored
the fires in Ferguson and they ignored
an tpho violence and they ignored so
many other things and now they want to
act like it's threatening to fact-check
media I'm just laughing because if
you're asking sincere questions about
the people in charge you're obviously
working for Vladimir Putin so good luck
with your new Russian masters Dina I had
Russian salad dressing earlier this week
so I was like I guess I'm a spy or
something
it's unbelievable thank you for joining
us I appreciate it